bonjour je m'appelle Benjamin guilla je
suis responsable des relations avec les
publics et de l'action culturelle pour
les scènes de Guill encour aujourd'hui
je vais vous présenter trois bonnes
raisons de vous rendre à la batterie et
plus précisément à l'auditorium de la
batterie pour assister à un concert avec
deux groupes dyaman et Adrian Clark
[Musique]
trio
première raison c'est une occasion rare
d'assister à un concert pop rock dans
cette salle l'auditorium de la batterie
qui est habituellement dédié aux musique
classique ou au jazz et cette salle est
apprécié pour ses qualités acoustiques
le confort des sièges et la proximité
qu'elle permet entre le public et les
artistes la seconde raison tient au
répertoire
emprunté au Beatles Queen le répertoire
pop rock notamment la pop rock
britannique qui est revisité par des
arrangements audacieux par les musiciens
donc de Adrian Clark trio musicien et
chanteuse jazz
[Musique]
aguéri la troisème raison
c'est de prolonger la soirée avec la
musique captivante et ensorcelante de
delaman c'est difficile de classer la
musique de del Yaman entre pop rock
Dream rock
rock enfin bref c'est une musique qui a
un caractère cinématographique et qui a
qui sait d'ailleurs prêter au
[Musique]
cinéma
c'était les trois bonnes raisons d'aller
voir D Yaman et Adrian Clark trio à
l'auditorium de la batterie le samedi 3
février à
20h30